[Musique]
l'invasion d'ukraine par la russie
l'hiver dernier a secoué l'échiquier
mondial au canada cela a donné lieu à
l'ouverture d'un vieux débat un débat
qu'on croyait clos depuis plus de 15 ans
tout d'abord notre position au niveau de
la défense des missiles balistiques n'a
pas changé dans nos plans de la
modernisation de nos rangs nous allons
avoir des conversations sur la meilleure
façon de le faire le canada on lance
alors subtilement l'idée de participer
au programme américain de défense
antimissile balistique le fameux
bouclier antimissile pourquoi le
gouvernement trudeau rêva lui si ces
options principalement à cause de
l'invasion d'ukraine par la russie cette
attaque change la donne en matière de
défense intercontinental en cas
d'attaqué le canada pourrait détecter
des missiles intercontinentaux
mais serait incapable de les intercepter
faute de moyens et même si le scénario
est jugé peu probable les américains ne
seraient pas obligés nous défendre la
raison est simple le canada n'a jamais
adhéré au programme de défense
antimissile américain une décision prise
en 2005 nous ne participerons pas au
système a mérité de défense antimissile
la décision n'a rien de scientifique
jamais d'efficacité ni la pertinence du
bouclier l'entité soulever non cette
décision est purement politique
en 2005 on estimait que s'impliquer dans
le projet risquait de souffler sur les
braises des tensions internationales
la sécurité demeure une priorité commune
vi dans son discours le ministre des
affaires étrangères de l'époque pierre
pettigrew laissé entendre que dans un
contexte politique différent le
gouvernement pourrait revenir sur sa
décision
le bouclier antimissile américain a
comme objectif de détecter et de
détruire les missiles balistiques
ennemis lancé en direction du territoire
américain au début des années 2000 la
corée du nord représente la principale
menace ce système de défense mère terre
espace est principalement déployés
pendant la ska et en californie il
comprend une quarantaine de radars
quarante quatre missiles antibalistiques
et 38 navires capables de suivre et
d'abattre un missile en plus de disposer
de sa télé de détection le bouclier
comprend aussi cette batterie de défense
antimissile à haute altitude dit fab un
système conçu pour détruire des missiles
balistiques en s'écrasant contre eux en
fonction depuis novembre 2004 le
bouclier américain a été conçu pour
faire face au tir d'une vingtaine de
missiles balistiques simultanément le
système d'interception n'est donc pas à
toute épreuve d'ailleurs on l'a testé
dix neuf fois
on estime la probabilité de neutraliser
une attaque à 56% c'est donc dire qu'une
attaque d'importance aurait des chances
d'atteindre ses cibles
et que dire de son efficacité contre les
nouveaux missiles hypersonique des armes
qualifiées d'invisibles est détectable
ces armes valeur entre 10 et 20 fois la
vitesse du son à basse altitude en
zigzaguant vers leur cible la russie la
chine et la corée du nord en compterait
dans leur arsenal
même si en juin 2022 le canada s'est
engagé à investir plus de 5 milliards de
dollars pour moderniser et accroître sa
défense continentale rien ne semble
indiquer que sa position sur le bouclier
n'est changé l'idée du bouclier
antimissile a une longue feuille de
route le 23 mars 1983 en pleine guerre
froide alors eagle alors président des
états unis lance son projet surnommé la
guerre des étoiles tout comme le
bouclier actuelle il vise à protéger les
états unis d'une attaque massive de
missiles nucléaires soviétiques
à cette époque la technologie n'est pas
suffisamment avancée pour que le projet
prenne et fille
quarante ans plus tard la menace n'a pas
changé on craint toujours les dirigeants
du kremlin
[Musique]